the idea systemic racism is not that
people are operating with racist mindset
were racist intention it's that is a
system that was originally designed to
produce races outcomes and it is
continuing to produce them regard as the
detent of people within that system to
policing through prosecution through
incarceration the criminal justice
system has produced massive declines in
crime since the 1990s and those declines
having geared primarily to the benefit
of black and brown communities across
the country is their overwhelming
evidence that America's criminal justice
system is racist that was the subject of
an online Soho forum debate held on
Wednesday June 24th 2020 sponsored by
reason arguing that America's criminal
justice system is in fact racist was
Radley Balko an opinion writer for The
Washington Post a former senior editor
at Reason BALCO is also the author of
the books rise of the warrior cop and
the cadaver King and the country dentist
defending America's criminal justice
system against the charge of racism was
the Manhattan Institute's Raphael Manuel
who is also a contributing editor for
city journal here's Radley Balko vs.
Raphael Manuel in an online debate
moderated by Soho forum director Jean
Epstein
tonight's resolution reads there is
overwhelming evidence that the criminal
justice system is racist speaking for
the affirmative Radley Balko journalist
at the Washington Post speaking for the
negative raphael manuel deputy director
of legal policy at the manhattan
institute when each of you has five
minutes and one minute remaining in your
allotted time i'll be briefly
interrupting to inform you Jane please
close the initial vote defending the
resolution Radley Balko
Radley you have seventeen and a half
minutes allotted to you you can take it
all or you can fall short either way
I'll keep time Radley
take it away thanks and thanks for
thinking me inviting to participate in
this just last week Theodore Johnson may
a black conservative or the National
Review about his experiences with
racial profiling by police uh he noted
the fact that over the course of his
life had been pulled over more than 40
times including one time that unjustly
landing in jail we noted that he has
black friends and family members of that
similar experiences Tim Scott be
conservative black senator from South
Carolina several years on the floor of
the US Senate talked about his own
experiences racial racial profiling and
how he had been unjustly pulled over in
fact noted that his chief of staff had
started driving a less expensive car
because he'd been pulled over because
police officers had mistaken him for a
drug dealer which was a black man
driving an expensive car when I talked
to racism about racism Colonel Justice
and I like to ask conservatives do you
think people like Tim statin Theodore
Johnson are lying you think they're
making these stories up and I would
guess that most would say no and then I
would ask me don't believe them or if
you do believe them excuse me why do you
believe them but not the countless other
black people who talk about told us
about similar experiences or spoken up
about certain experiences the evidence
of systemic systemic racism in our
criminal justice system isn't just
persuasive it's overwhelming for the
last couple of years I've been
collecting studies surveys and reports
on this matter and I've collected a
catalogue close to 300 now and which can
find at the Washington Post the ratio of
studies surveys and reports that have
found racial disparities to those that
haven't as about 25 to 1 studies show
racially disparate outcomes and police
stopped researches how bail is
administered who gets arrested who gets
pulled over who gets fine who gets
arrested for not paying fines who gets
charged for possessing drugs who gets
leniency when prosecutors offer plea
bargains who gets leniency when judges
issue sentences who gets parole or
probation who gets hit with technical
violations while on parole parole or
probation which kids get cited arrested
when cops work in schools who gets
picked for juries who gets put in
solitary confinement on whom cops use
force how much force they used who gets
the death penalty who cops kill and who
gets commutations and pardons um none of
this should really be surprising the
criminal justice system was designed
honed and evolved during the Jim Crow
era
and there's plenty of historical
evidence a deluge of historical evidence
showing that for most much of the Jim
Crow era the criminal justice system was
designed to preserve the racial
hierarchy that existed during Jim Crow
that is it was designed to sort of keep
black people in their place um I don't
think anyone who's in the state would
deny that Jim Crow era existed that
there was racial segregation during that
era and that our institutions existed to
sort of perpetuate that segregation the
fact is though those those institutions
survived Jim Crow that Jim Crow is gone
but those those institutions survived
and the idea that situations that were
built and designed to preserve racial
hierarchy would suddenly stop doing that
just because Jim Crow in a way I think
defies for Julie um when we talk about
systemic racism I think people
mistakenly think that systemic racism
the charge of systemic racism means that
every single person in the criminal
justice system is racist that is not
what systemic racism means Democrats ISM
means that we have a system that was
designed to to perpetuate racially
disparate outcomes and continues to do
so the example I like to give is st.
Louis County Missouri shortly after the
Ferguson protests began I went to st.
Louis County Missouri to do some
reporting and I went to all the county
excuse me a lot of cities other than
Ferguson in st. Louis County st. Louis
County has an ungodly number of cities
over 90 municipalities exist in this one
County and there's a reason for that
back in the the mid 20th century when
white people started to mean st. Louis
they would flee st. Louis they would
move out into the county black people
would then the black middle-class for
them started also moving into the county
also to get out of the city and white
people would sort of pick up and move a
mile or a half mile over and start a new
city basically it was this perpetual
pattern of white people sort of picking
up and moving as black people moved into
their neighborhoods and this created
what would locally called the postage
stamp cities all over st. Louis County
and those exists today the problem is
each of these little cities has its own
Police Department and some City Council
and they all have to draw a salary and
in st. Louis County the primary source
of revenue for these municipalities are
fine
and fees administered by municipal
courts these are things like traffic
violations for jaywalking for exceeding
occupancy permits and houses and when I
found when I went there is if you talk
to two people who live in black areas of
st. Louis County they are perpetually
harassed by cops because the police
officers and there's plenty of evidence
of this are basically told by their City
Council's to treat the people who live
in these cities as ATM machines for the
city in fact these municipal cops don't
really solve crimes that there's a
serious crime is handled by the county
police these city cops exist solely to
shake people down to provide revenue for
their local towns and cities and the the
the part where the systemic racism comes
in here is that the primary source of
revenue in st. Louis County Principality
is a sales tax well the poor a city is
the less money it's going to get from a
sales tax right and of course there is a
correlation between poverty and the
percentage of a county that is black and
so what we actually find is that the
blacker some of these cities are the
more reliant they are on fines and fees
for revenue that is the more likely it
is that they're police officers are
shaking down their residents for with
these these you know excessive fines and
fees we found some count some cities in
st. Louis County where there had been
twenty even thirty arrest warrants
issued for every resident of the county
because if you can't pay these and it
can't get to court then you get an
arrest warrant issued for you I'm
talking to people who live in these guys
this was overwhelming these people
people who lived in some of these towns
had multiple arrest warrants they were
scared every time they went out in their
car and this was a system that was
designed sort of to to to not only to
shake people down but also to the the
blackery City was the more reliant it
was on these fines and fees and so you
thought you could have a system where
basically a city in st. Louis County may
have a black City Council it may have a
majority black police department but it
was more reliant on fines and fees than
wealthier cities and therefore those
officers were going to be more harassing
at the residents of those towns and so
you could have a system where none of
the people who operated with invested
were to slay racist a lot of them were
black themselves but this is a system
that had a racially despaired outcome
that preyed on black residents more than
white residents and that was the result
in the direct product of of historical
sort of racism it was a legacy of the
system of white people sort of fleeing
st. Louis as a city um that's one
example but you can see similar examples
all over the country and sort of how
these systems how black neighborhoods
are policed versus white neighborhoods
and how black neighborhoods
socio-historical been broken up you can
find this sort of across to all various
aspects of our society but you see it
most pronounced in policing in the
criminal justice system so let's look at
the data I'm gonna go I can't obviously
go through all three hundred or so
studies that have looked at over the
last couple of years but I can give you
some highlights so just last May there
was a massive study of 95 million
traffic stops by 56 police agencies in
the United States during 2011 in 2018
the study found that black motorists are
far more likely to be pulled over the
white motorists but interestingly as the
day grew darker the time of day through
darker of the discrepancy narrowed
suggesting that when police couldn't
actually see the race of the drivers
they were less likely to racially
profile that's a pretty good indication
that these stops weren't necessarily
based on merit but that race was a a
driving factor in why police were
pulling people over the study also found
that black people were far more likely
to be searched after a stop even though
the searches of white people were more
likely to find contraband
now this last part is important and it's
consistent with countless other studies
we've seen of traffic stops nearly every
study to look at traffic stops and
searches is found that black people are
more likely to be searched by police and
also that white people searches of white
people are more likely to turn up
dallisa drugs for weapons we've seen
this in studies of stops in Cincinnati
Austin Washington DC Southern California
Connecticut Springfield Missouri
Burlington Vermont the entire state of
Vermont North Carolina st. Louis County
the list goes on and on and on let's
move to the drug war study after study
has shown that the blacks and whites
both use and distribute
similar rates black people are far more
likely to be arrested charged and
convicted and to get more jail time once
they are convicted in New York City
black people are eight times more likely
to be arrested for marijuana possession
the Manhattan is 15 times more likely
over the rest of the country it ranges
from slightly more likely to 40 or 50
times more likely inherit a one really
interesting example a few years ago
Harris County Tennessee
excuse me Harris County Texas the home
in Houston discovered that its crime lab
had been issuing false positives and
drug possession cases so officials went
back and retested thousands of cases
what they found in the end result is
that black people the black people make
made only 20% of Eros county's
population they made up 60% of the
wrongful possession of narcotics cases a
2017 report done by reason itself found
the vast majority of civil asset
forfeitures in Chicago were in black
neighborhoods and though forfeiture is
often touted as a way to prevent drug
kingpins from keeping ill-gotten gains
the median value of the property seized
was a 1,000 $49 we can look at jury
selection studies have consistently
shown that prosecutors strike black
people from juries at far higher rates
than white people
a study of ten years of trials in
Philadelphia found that prosecutors 452
percent of black jurors versus 23
percent of white a 2011 study twenty
years of trials by the Michigan State
Law School found similar numbers
prosecutors struck 53 percent of black
jurors versus 26 percent of way he also
the authors of that study crunched the
numbers and estimated that the odds of a
discrepancy that big occurring from a
race-neutral selection was about one in
ten trillion let's look at sentencing
here to study after study has found that
when white and black defendants have
similar criminal histories and convicted
of similar crimes judges consistently
sentence black people the more prison
time a 20-17 study by the US Sentencing
Commission found that black people on
average get 20% longer sentences for
similar crimes even after adjusting for
age and criminal history black people
are consistently more likely to get
sentencing enhancements and authorized
by federal drug control excuse me gun
control laws a New Jersey study found
that black in the two
people made up 96% of defendants
sentenced to extra time in to the
state's drug free school zones law look
at bail recent Columbia University study
found that black people are far more
likely to be taint to detained pretrial
when accused of similar plot crimes even
after adjusting for criminal histories
black people are also also less likely
to be paroled and more likely to be
violated from parole of probation for
what are called technical offenses these
are offenses where the person didn't
actually commit a new crime but you know
missed a curfew or associated with the
wrong people or other sort of technical
administrative offences let's look at
gang lost a lot of cities and states
have passed laws that offer sentencing
enhancements if you're associated with
the gang a recent study found that more
than half of the people on Mississippi's
gang registry were actually white
generally people were associated with
white supremacist groups and yet the
same study found that every single
person prosecuted on the state's gang
law from twenty thousand ten to twenty
thousand seventeen was white every
single person we could look at police
use of force what we found and we look
at police's of course is a city after
City after City police overwhelming we
used the vast majority of force - excuse
me disproportionate amount of force on
black people attend they tend to use
more force on black people particularly
under similar circumstances there is a
there was a a recent a really
interesting recent study that looked at
911 and what the study found is that
when police officers were sent when
9-1-1 calls sent leaves officers to
white or mixed race neighborhoods white
and black officers used force at about
the same rates but when a 911 call sent
his officers to black neighborhoods
majority black neighborhoods white
officers were much much more likely to
use force in black officers and more
likely to use greater degrees of force
um one of the most interesting areas and
then I'll wrap up I think that I found
in studying this is something I hadn't
even really thought much about until I
started compiling studies and that's
this issue of colorism so stuck study
after study has found that not only our
black people drennan generally treated
worse than the criminal justice system
than white people but the blacker a
person is the worse they're treated by
the criminal justice system in fact it's
almost on a continuum as your skin color
gets darker and darker and darker these
discrepancies that we see are more and
more likely to affect you and affect you
in more severe ways now the counter to
all of this is that is generally that
black people commit crimes at a higher
rate than white people therefore we
should expect them to be treated worse
by the criminal justice system I would
submit that if you look at the studies
that have compiled in this survey at the
Washington Post a lot of these studies
control for things like crime rates and
criminal records from the past um but
this colorism thing is really
interesting because you know it isn't
that black er people commit more crimes
than lighter-skinned black people right
you believe that then you have to likely
subscribe to some sort of biological or
genetic origin of criminality uh for the
reason why black people commit crimes at
higher rates as opposed to sort of
cultural or discriminate it's thurible
discrimination um and you know I would
submit that nobody's for participating
in or viewing this debate I would hope
subscribes to the idea that there's some
sort of genetic predisposition to
criminality and black people if the
criminal justice system is treating
darker skinned black people worse than
lighter skinned black people I think
that's a pretty good indication that the
criminal justice system itself is
judging people based on the color of
their skin and not on
the severity of the crimes or their
criminal histories I'll just wrap up by
saying I think again you know I couldn't
I wish I could I could take another hour
and go through all the data that I've
compiled over the last couple of years
but I had somebody who when I first got
into this I was skeptical of the notion
that racial discrimination was rampant
in the criminal justice system I would
submit that you can't work on this beat
for very long and still hold to that
that assumption but evidence is just
overwhelming and it hits you in the face
of every day that you look at this and
it's a reason why I completely sort of
changed the way I think about these
issues thanks and I look forward to
Raphael's response thank you Radley
Raphael you have the same seventeen and
a half minutes to speak for the negative
on the resolution take it away
Raphael oh thank you I like to actually
start by saying thank you to Eugene and
the Soho forum from the invitation and
thank you to Radley for the challenge
I've long been a fan of these debates
I've actually I was an attendee of the
very first Soho forum back in 2016
in which my Manhattan Institute
colleague Heather McDonald emerged
victorious a feat I hope I'm able to
pull off your night and you know with
the temperature of of the ongoing debate
about policing in criminal justice in
America right now reaching what seems
like an all-time high
I think measured and thoughtful
exchanges of ideas are important and so
I'm really grateful for the opportunity
to contribute to this dialogue and I
hope that I'm able to do justice to an
argument that I'm making in defense of
institutions that well most certainly
are imperfect nonetheless have produced
an incredible amount of good for many of
the most vulnerable among us and so with
that here let's let's go let's get to
the question at hand which is is there
overwhelming evidence that the criminal
justice system is racist and despite a
well delivered opening statement by my
opponent the answer remains no and to
understand why I think we have to start
with the question of what it means for a
system to be racist in this case mostly
against black Americans and that takes
to me to the first of six critiques that
I have of resins argue and the first
that Bradley's working definition of
systemic racism in the context of our
debate here tonight is has he put it
recently in his column to which he made
reference it's satisfied when systems
and institutions quote produced racially
disparate outcomes regardless of the
intentions of people who work within
them now this sets an artificially low
bar by sidestepping intent and thereby
relieving proponents of this view of the
responsibility of establishing not just
that the criminal justice system
produces racially disparate outcomes but
that it is operated for the purpose of
producing those outcomes after all there
is no such thing as accidental racism
right and so on the right question on
that question the evidence is most
certainly not overwhelming now if you
read the article that the Radley
reference the title of which inspired
this debate what you'll see are a ton of
examples many of which are duplicated by
the way of my second critique which is
that in order to make his point mr.
BALCO is conflating racial disparities
with racism and he does this by focusing
on the criminal justice system's outputs
things like traffic stops citations
arrests use of four sentences etc but he
does that without considering the inputs
to the system that is in most cases
without actually controlling for the
factors besides racial animus that could
often go a long way toward explaining
pretty big chunks of the disparities on
which he hangs his hat and doing this
allows him to attribute to the system
responsibility for outcomes that are
driven largely by many of those who find
themselves and snared by it
I didn't hear a couple of examples of
what I mean so a lot of people have been
pointing to a study recently published
by the National Academy of Sciences
which puts the odds of black men dying
at the hands of police at one in 1,000
to double the odds for men generally now
if you believe that this disparity
constitutes prima facie evidence of
racism as mr. BALCO seems to consider
that the very same studies show that the
odds of women dying at the hands of
police we're just one in thirty-three
thousand now what can we conclude from
this that the criminal justice system is
fairly characterized by rabid misandry
of course not all right and so let's go
to my second example Radleys
article summarizes the blurbs regarding
the drug war as follows quote black
people are consistently arrested charged
and convicted of drug crimes including
possession distribution and conspiracy
at far higher rates than white people
this despite research showing that both
races use and sell drugs at about the
same rate and quote now the problem with
this framing is that controlling for use
in sale rates is insufficient to
establish that these disparities by and
large reflect racial animus for one
thing it fails to account for how police
resources are deployed which is often a
function of disparate violent crime
rates violent crime is not evenly
distributed throughout the country
geographically it's not evenly
distributed throughout the states it's
not evenly distributed in cities or even
neighborhoods right consider consider
the city of Chicago for example where
the 2018 homicide rate for just four
contiguous community areas nice Garfield
Park West Garfield Park Humboldt Park in
Austin was at sixty three point seven
five per 100,000 triple the citywide
rate of 20 per 100,000 and it was about
ten times the national rate which is
about five for 100,000 nor is the
demographic distribution of violent
crime even those four community areas in
Chicago are almost entirely comprised of
black and Latino residents and the
unfortunate reality is that when it
comes to some of the most violent crimes
homicide in particular that uneven
demographic distribution persists at the
national level indeed while black men
constitute about seven percent of the
nation's population they comprise close
to half of no murder victims in 2018 and
historically based on homicide data from
1980 to 2008 published by the Bureau of
Justice Statistics blacks are about six
times more likely to be the victim of a
homicide in their white counterparts
they're about eight times more likely to
be the perpetrators of a homicide in
2016 a study published by the annals of
internal medicine found that black men
were more than 10 times more likely to
be the victim of a homicide than their
white counterparts that year and so the
question really is whether it is
legitimate for police to focus their
attention on the places in which finally
it's so elevated and on the people
suspected of driving that crime and the
answer that question is yes deploying
scarce resources in response to
disparate rates of serious violent crime
is not only legitimate but it's also
race-neutral and yet what we see in the
sort of argument that that Radley is
making here tonight is a consistent
failure to account for how legitimate
disparities and resource deployment
inform the likelihood of encounters that
produce the racially disparate outcomes
if there are more police in black
neighborhoods you're going to have more
police encounters with black men in them
right on this second point still be it
there's it's there something else that
the argument about the drug war that the
Radley makes in his article ignores
which is the reality that drug
enforcement is often pretextual as an
attack on violent crime and that goes
for other low-level crime enforcement in
other words how and where police and
prosecutors and forced drug laws and
other lower level offenses is not only
or even mainly a function of drug use or
drug sales but rather a violent crime
which is something that they are seeking
to reduce through drug enforcement based
on their perception a reasonable
perception that a substantial overlap
between drug offenders and violent
criminals and high crime neighborhoods
exists and a few statistics revealed
that those perceptions are not crazy in
2017 Baltimore police identified 118
murder suspects more than 70% of them
had at least one drug arrest in their
criminal history
a recent Bureau of Justice Statistics
study on recidivism found that more than
three-quarters of released drug
offenders from state prisons would go on
to be Rios for a non drug crime more
than a third would go on to be rheostat
for a violent crime specifically now
this reality is explained by it helps
explain I think why the anti-drug Abuse
Act of 1986 which by the way is to
establish the 100 to one sentencing
disparity which would crack and powder
cocaine which is often cited as evidence
of racism was co-sponsored by 16 of the
19 members of the Congressional Black
Caucus at the time and this relates to a
point that I'm going to expand on
shortly now you can say and I might even
agree with you that this doesn't change
the moral philosophical case against the
drug war and if someone who leans pretty
libertarian myself I'd sympathize but I
don't think you can fault
makers from operating pursuant to the
public policy case for drug enforcement
which seeks to answer different
questions in the moral philosophical
question on a case right and and most
importantly that public policy case is
raised neutral insofar as it's driven by
violence now lastly on this this second
critique I'll note that the drug war is
actually not driving racial disparities
in the black incarceration which i think
is a pretty important point to make
right well blacks constitute
approximately 35 percent of violent
offenders 43 percent of weapon offenders
26 percent of property for offenders and
28 percent of drug offenders in state
prisons what you need to know is that
where we do release every single drug
offender tomorrow the black percentage
of the state prison populations would
not change in fact it would actually
increase very slightly
now the third critique I had here is
that all the disparities that Bradley is
focused on in his remarks in his article
are disparities in enforcement data as
if enforcement statistics rebbe only the
outputs that our criminal justice system
produces well they're not all right
Radley's remark to ignore but is perhaps
the most important output of our
criminal justice system over the last 30
years crime declines sigmoids through
policing through prosecution through
incarceration the criminal justice
system has produced massive declines in
crime since the 1990s and those declines
have been here primarily to the benefit
of black and brown communities across
the country
I consider the following excerpt from a
book by NYU sociologist Patrick
Jardine's kind of uneasy peace which by
the way was very critical of policing
and incarceration he writes quote even
the staunchest critics of mass
incarceration acknowledged that the
expansion of the imprisoned population
contributed to the defining violence on
this point he can see its quote there is
no longer much debate and he goes on
quote the impact of the decline in
homicide on the life expectancy of black
men is roughly equivalent to the impact
of eliminating obesity altogether for
every 100,000 black men over 1,000 more
years of time with friends and family
have been preserved because of the drop
in the murder rate thank quote his book
presents a bountiful literature showing
among other things that declines in
violent crime in black neighborhoods
improved as you
occasional outcomes increased up or both
upward mobility which he wrote by the
way is quote much less likely in cities
with high levels of violence
now the unequal distribution of the
benefits of crime-fighting complicates
mr. balco's argument here because there
just isn't a particularly good
explanation for why a system apparently
designed and operated for the purpose of
oppressing a racial minority which so
disproportionately benefit members of
that minority when the system achieves
its stated goals according to the
leaders at the system's Helms now
another reality that is seen Congress
with the resolution my opponent is
depending here tonight is that the
criminal justice system is the criminal
justice systems responsiveness to calls
for reform which five-way have led to
reductions in both arrests and
incarceration that again have
disproportionately benefited black
Americans as my Manhattan Institute
colleague Coleman Hughes recently put it
quote from 2001 to 2017 the
incarceration rate for black men
declined by 34 percent now let's just
consider what's happened since George
Floyd's reprehensible death prompted
nationwide protests and call through the
forum right yusin's had several major
pieces of legislation proposed at the
federal level you've had police
departments including the NYPD just
disbanded which just disbanded it's
plain clothes anti-crime teams change
internal policies and here in New York
State we've had Governor Cuomo signed
into law ten police reform those and all
this without a change in the composition
of the players that make up the system
which begs the question why would a
system operated for the purpose of
depressing minorities he calls for
reform but not only to come
disproportionately from minority
communities but stemmed from protests in
response to the killing of a black man
and reinvigorated a movement led by an
organization called black lives matter
it wouldn't my fifth critique here is
that Radley's definition of systemic
racism allows him to conveniently ignore
the role that black and brown americans
play as police officers investigators
prosecutors judges law makers and even
voters in bringing about the racially
disparate outcomes
the pieces are overwhelmingly against
race
- 2015 report by governing almost 28% of
police officers and minorities in his
thoughtful book locking up our own James
Forman jr. every tightly documents this
story highlighting that 64 percent of
black respondents to a Sentencing
Project survey for example stated that
they thought courts were not harsh
enough on criminals these attitudes were
very well documented by Michael J
fourtner and his great book silent black
majority which sets which which sets out
the role that black New Yorkers have
played and pushing the now-infamous
Rockefeller drug laws over the finish
line all right so the implication in my
opponents argument is that to the extent
that people who look like me contribute
in various ways to the criminal justice
system's outputs they do so as unwitting
participants duped into carrying out
their own oppression this is both
implausible it's also offensive all
right now fourtner's book also
characterized the criminal justice
system as quote disaggregated and
uncoordinated or quote almost a non
system and this is salient because it
takes me to my sixth and final point at
its root Radley's central thesis the
criminal justice system was designed to
achieve the results of racially
disparate enforcement against blacks in
a way that renders irrelevant the
intentions of the systems operators
attributes to the federal state and
local governments of the United States a
level of organizational and managerial
aptitude but no self-respecting
libertarian would ever attribute to the
state right at its core what mr. BALCO
is alleging here is to quote the great
George Costanza that minorities mostly
blacks have quote become the target of a
systematic process of intimidation and
manipulation the likes of which well you
get my point and so given that the whole
forum is very much libertarian turf I
hope that I don't have to try too hard
to advance your skepticism of the claim
but institutions that constitute our
criminal justice systems were erected to
effectively and consistently bring about
certain results over generations
in such a way that as my opponent would
have you believe renders it impervious
to the intentions of its operators I
don't think that it's hard to find that
impossible I don't know about you I I
just can't by the idea that such a large
collection of government agencies is
capable of that kind of success and so I
want to end by by saying that that doe
ray
unjustifiable police violence is
something that should seriously concern
us all and and so it's important for us
to engage the arguments that have
resurfaced in the wake of George Floyd's
truly infuriating death head-on and I
want you to know that I understand
personally the concerns about racial
disparities given stories like mr. Floyd
as well as the stained history of law
enforcement here in the United States
and while I believe the black and brown
communities have disproportionately
enjoyed the benefits produced by the
American criminal justice system I also
understand that we have
disproportionately borne some of the
costs and we can acknowledge all of that
without throwing the baby out with the
bathwater which as we now see with the
rise in popularity of police and prison
abolition is new in America is the
logical extension of the argument that
mr. BALCO made here and that argument
does not as I see it hold up under close
scrutiny however that there is not
overwhelming evidence that the criminal
justice system is racist doesn't mean
but there isn't work to be done and that
there is work to be done is no reason to
refrain from defending the system
against the charge of racism which is
something I think I hope I have done
capably hidden it thank you okay Thank
You Raphael Radley we now go to the
rebuttal part of the evening
Bradley you get five minutes of rebuttal
take it away Radley well I'll start in
the institution the reveal sites studies
to rebut me that I didn't actually cite
in my argument you know his point about
outcomes versus inputs doesn't explain
for example why prosecutors are over
overwhelmingly likely to strike black
people from jurors instead of white
people it's denies black people
participation in the criminal justice
system and their civic responsibility to
serve on juries also denies black
defendants the right to have a
representative jury at trial by their
peers it doesn't account for the fact
that I mentioned several times the
police are much more likely to search
black motorist after stopping them even
though searches of white motors
consistently turn out more illegal drugs
and and it was
more likely to turn them on doesn't it
doesn't address the fact that you look
at the death penalty of the race of the
victim in a death them in a murder case
is much more likely determine the death
penalty where the death bones apply than
anything else people who kill white
people are much more likely to get to
death than other people who kill black
people it doesn't account for you know
various other aspects that will just
actually be the idea that you factor in
crime rates or the rate of crime in
neighborhoods that are policed I've
already been accounted for in the
studies had already been adjusted for um
a good example this is stop and frisk
New York Times analysis found that there
was no correlation between where New
York police officers conducted stop and
frisks and the number of guns seized
from those particular communities the
vast majority of people who were stopped
and frisked while stopped and frisked
was the policy of New York City we're
innocent about ninety percent were in
about ninety percent were also black or
Latino and so what you have here is a
policy that disproportionately affects
minority communities overwhelmingly
harasses and subjects innocent people to
these sorta Milley aiding searches on
the street and that does very very
little in terms of actually addressing
gun issues in the neighborhoods where
guns are a problem as for the idea that
sort of we send police officers into
communities where the most looters most
crime others most violent crime the
Washington Post did a study earlier this
year that found that police are actually
really bad at stopping on homicides and
they're worse at solving homicides and
black and black communities back if I
had the number of correct and it may be
misremembering is slightly but it's let
I believe less than thirty percent of
black murders of black people in Chicago
were solved by and Chicago Police
Department now if the whole idea of
we're sending cops into your
neighborhood to protect you from violent
crime and so you're gonna have to put up
with these proportionate stops and
searches and arrests you know in order
to promote your own safety you would
think that police would actually have a
better or do a better job of solving
crimes in those communities
Rafael cites the the card the decline in
the crime rate since the mid-1990s as a
as a sort of justification for some of
these racial disparities or suggesting
that those of us who are upset about
racial disparities equal justice and
don't factor in the number of the
benefits of black communities by the
decline in crime but there's no evidence
actually that incarceration and
aggressive policing are responsible for
the drop in the crime rate in fact
studies I've seen attribute
incarceration and partial policies to
about five to twenty percent of the
crime drop that we've seen since the
mid-1990s in fact criminologists are
constantly arguing with each other about
what caused the crime drop I see very
little evidence that we should attribute
any or most of it to aggressive policing
or mass incarceration or policies that
led to mass incarceration we've seen
everything was sort of led let dilution
to abortion to the aging population I
mean there are all sorts of factors the
idea that we should sort of hang our hat
on the fact that you know putting more
people in prison and putting more
disproportionate number of minority
people in prison who are subjecting them
to aggressive policing is somehow saving
them you know there's not a lot of data
to back that up
Rafael also talks about unwitting
participants in fact that minority
people in the criminal justice system
that they're somehow being duped
I would say that lots of minorities in
the criminal justice system have spoken
out about the very same things that I'm
talking about the National Association
of black police officers regularly
decries racial profiling craving you
cries discrepancies in the way the drug
laws are enforced um there are lots of
groups within the criminal justice
system they've been raising these very
same issues it's not that they don't see
them or that they're unwilling dupes
it's that they still sort of believe in
public service but they're raised they
want to fix the problems within it but
it's Rafael's final point that is that
suggesting the system is racist ascribes
to it a certain aptitude that no
libertarian should sort of think a
government is capable of
nobody's suggesting that this is a
conspiracy but this is organized that
there's a you know zoom meeting police
officers every morning oh sure there's
some zoom meeting please observing will
discuss how they're going to oppress
minority people the argument is that
this is a system that was built and
designed and honed and evolved in an era
where everyone agrees that there was
systematic racism and discrimination in
America and these are the same
institutions that survive today and that
without sort of going through and and
you know carefully studying examining
what in those systems we need to get rid
of or change in order to affect sort of
purge it of those inclinations that's
what we need to do there's no there's no
argument that this is some sort of
organized conspiracy of oppression and
racism it's that these systems were
designed for that and these are the same
systems we use today and we need to sort
of go through and figure out what what
we need to change to make them better I
thanks yeah okay yeah I'm rather you get
a little bit of extra time on your
rebuttal because rather took a little
bit of action so take it away
Radley with your rebuttal thank you
thank you I I miss a little bit of that
because there's there's a bit of jumping
around but I'm gonna try and quickly
respond to to at least the some of the
points that jumped out at me I mean the
first thing is this argument that there
are these you know alternative you know
explanations for a huge chunk to the
crime decline really is his basis I mean
Radley can stay that there isn't a lot
of evidence in support of this but but
the reality is is that there is I've
cited it much of my work you know even
the Sentencing Project in a 2005 report
came out and said that 25 percent of
that crime decline in the 1990s can be
attributed to incarceration
you know again this idea that it's not
but this isn't an organized effort again
I think undermines the claim insofar as
at least if you subscribe to the idea
that racism or showing racism requires a
showing of intent again you cannot be
accidentally racist this idea that you
know this this this system just kind of
accidentally produces these outcomes
without any intent is really or at least
due to the intent of
you know who are dead today it really
just events is one of two things which
is either a conspiracy argument or just
an accidental racism argument either
which really holds water
this idea that abortion drove a chunk of
the crime decline that came anywhere
close to things like imprisonment or
more aggressive proactive policing is
interesting to explore because what it
implies especially given the rate of
black abortion is that there is some
higher propensity for black children to
grow up to be criminals and therefore by
taking them out of the world
preemptively you make way for a decline
in crime not I don't find that
convincing nor do I see any real
evidence of that I would point people
here to bury lancers book which
addresses in great detail both the
abortion and lead poisoning arguments
you know this idea that that the study
is that Radley sets out in his article
by and large control for the relevant
factors that are necessary to control
for in order to isolate racial animus
really just as a mischaracterization I
went through as he was talking I was
able to get through the first nineteen
studies that he cites in in that
Washington Post article none of them had
any where near sufficient controls or
robust effects to to to actually isolate
racism right uh you know so when he says
a lot of these studies have these
controls I think what he means is that's
not very many at all you know we talked
about again outputs things like traffic
stops I would point into a study done in
New Jersey uh in the Garden State
Parkway which actually over a period of
time using high-tech cameras took
pictures of motorists and took a
cross-sectional sample of malodorous on
the Garden State Parkway and what it
found was the black motorist black male
motorist in particular were so much more
like me to speed than their counterparts
on the road that actually explain the
entirety of the gap in people being
pulled over by the years and State
Police you know so again that's not to
say that adding these controls will
always explain the entirety the gap but
I don't think it has to right the claim
here it's not that there isn't some
racism at some points in some
places within the criminal justice
system the claim here is that by and
large there are so much grace ISM in the
criminal justice system that it is
endemic to it such that we can
characterize the system as racist again
I just don't think that Rather's really
carried that argument here today you
know when we talk about things like stop
question and frisk again you know the
evidence really push back against grab
his characterization I'd point you to a
2014 study done by David Weisberg a
criminologist at George Mason which
actually found that in high crime
neighborhoods in New York City which
again had mostly minority populations
the added presence of police and the
knowledge within the public that police
were engaging more proactive activity
actually did have a significant
deterrent effect on crime such that the
fact that guns weren't recovered in a
huge amount of these stops isn't really
the point right the point is is that by
doing having these interactions you were
sending a signal that actually admit of
changing behavior you're still allowing
police to achieve their goal again
doesn't mean that was the best way to go
about it the that's beside the point
that we're debating here today the point
that we're debating here today is
whether those actions were driven by
racial animus against a black people I
don't think that we can say that that's
the case so I'll stop a test ok well
that concludes the initial part of the
evening we now go to the Q&A part at any
time either of you can ask a question of
the other the moderator can do so that's
me or I can read questions that came in
from the audience you can do this at any
time but right now Radley is there a
question you'd like to put two raphael
or do you want to waive that and say you
two up to you you know as one let's go
back to stop and frisk I mean you know
we've stop and frisk it's a sort of
knowledge that police presence in these
communities is why crime went down in
these communities then why did crime
continue to go down after stop and frisk
ended I would just add that your your
colleague or the McDonald predicted that
there was going to be a massive surge in
crime violent crime in New York City
with the end of
risk that didn't happen so how do you
explain that well again saying that that
didn't happen is to abrogate the city's
crime data as if crime is experienced in
the aggregate and it's not right
crime is extremely concentrated within
the city of New York just as it's
extremely concentrated everywhere else
in the United States so to look at crime
trends in the city as a whole and say
well these were pretty flat irrespective
of how things changed is really the kind
of wrong measure which is why I decided
David weisburd study which does a micro
geographic analysis which is the right
unit of measurement here to look to see
how crime changes in specifically the
high crime areas and there there was a
very statistically significant effect
after all controls were entered into and
robustness checks for me the other thing
I would say here too is that stop and
frisk you know it's a term that we kind
of bandy about but there's actually a
lot of evidence to show that a pretty
big chunk of the interactions that were
recorded on UF 250s which were the forms
that my pretty officers had to submit
when they did a stop and frisk we're
actually not legally stopped and wrists
right you have to remember that there
was an incentive in place back then the
department created when it made stop
activity part of an Police Officers
evaluation and when police officers were
in low crime areas they were still held
to that standard which induced them to
record a lot of interactions that didn't
actually rise to the level of a stop and
frisk as stops interests right and one
of the ways we can kind of have some
circumstantial evidence of this being
the case is a recent piece of
legislation passed by the City Council
on the right to know act the right to
know acts premise which was passed in
2017 by the way the premise of the right
to Novack is that even after the big
decline in reported stops by the NYPD
people were still regularly consenting
to police searches such that activity
like that did not decrease all that much
and the conclusion was that they were
consenting based on an ignorance of
their right to withhold that consent and
so if the incentive structure in place
at the time can stop interest was near
its peak it was such that police
officers would have been incented to
record as Terry stops in interactions
that were actually consented to that
would actually change the trend lines
quite a bit and
you know I think that's something that
you have to consider to only comment on
that Radley no okay
Raphael do you have a question you want
to put to Radley no no I think let's
just go to audience questions I see that
there's a lot in the chat there so okay
well I want to what what put your
question to you both
just to clarify how far apart you are on
the issue of the course in the plummet
of the plummeting crime rate I take it
both of you agreed to the plummeting
crime rate did benefit blacks both of
you agree with that but it was a big
benefit to blacks and that in that sense
it it came a it it was sort of pro anti
racism rather than pro but radley your
position is that the two factors which
is incarceration and more aggressive
policing more incarceration more
aggressive policing those two factors
had no effect or did I hear you say is
like 15 to 20 percent could you clarify
your position on that the more
incarceration and more aggressive police
and affecting the plummeting crime rate
yeah the the the academic research puts
it that somewhere between 5 and 20
percent I guess why Peola understudied
is 25 percent even assuming it's it's 25
percent I mean that is that is 1/4 of
the crime drop in response to a massive
increase in mass incarceration so I
don't you know I think there are we
don't know exactly what caused the crime
drop also I would just like that that I
I mentioned I mentioned abortion as in
the course of discussing all the
theories that have been put forth by
criminologists for possible reasons for
the product I was not suggesting that I
personally believed that cause of crime
drop and it's a little disingenuous to
sort of accuse me of being a racist
because I cited a theory that many
criminologist have put out about what
caused the crime go alright well that
that clarifies things in terms of your
position on abortion
but like you were saying and I just jump
in one to say one thing gene well first
off I want to make clear that was
certainly not implying that you're
racist radley I don't think you would be
arguing your side of this of this
resolution if you were however I want to
just make clear that I'm not sure how
far apart we are on the causes of the
crime decline is really all that
relevant right the relevant point here
is that this question goes to intent
right in every single defender of the
criminal justice system every single
leader within the criminal justice
system that argues that those benefits
were attributable to their actions in
Vince's their own state of mind which is
important here because my argument is
that the criminal justice system is not
operated to hurt black people and if so
people like Bill Bratton or Dermot of
Dermot Shay or Ray Kelly or Rudy
Giuliani or whoever it is that you have
in mind William bar if their argument is
that these crime declines and your
premier leads to the benefit of blacks
when the system operates the way that
they think it should then that convinces
their own state of mind which is not a
racist state of mind and that is the
point that I'm making here today I I
would just go back to a point that and
again the idea of systemic racism is not
that people are operating with the
racist mindset were racist intention
it's that there's a system that was
originally designed to produce races
outcomes and it is continuing to produce
them regard as the attendant people
within that system but I also say that
just saying that the climbrate this
benefit of black people means the system
has benefit black people discounts the
untold aural damage that's been done
black communities by mass incarceration
is not just people incarcerated their
families studies showing that it spreads
almost like a disease throughout entire
communities that it's been devastating
to black communities so you know yes the
crime decline has benefited the question
is could we have gotten the same or
similar decline without putting you know
masses of people in prison or subjecting
people to giving people criminal records
you didn't deserve it which you know
Bexon for the rest of their lives could
we have done this they're trying to kind
of happen without all of it and I think
there's good evidence that it could have
okay so I actually knew and just being a
question that I've seen from the
audience that I also want to put to you
Brad Radley you're saying that even
though there are black police chiefs
even though you mentioned that the black
people in government in these st. Louis
suburbs are implementing certain things
you're basically saying that black
people are themselves have become
themselves agents in racism by becoming
a part of the criminal justice system
that black people are effectively
purveyors of racism toward their own
kind because of the systemic analysis
that you put forward is that a correct
clarification of your view without the
correct somebody I mean I think there
are black people a little justice to who
realize that the commitment of the
criminal justice system is racist and
try to change it from the inside but you
said in the case of Sam Lewis for
example boy deity there many black
police chiefs and many others there are
black cops so the many black people
disproportionately aren't black people
disproportionately represented in the
criminal justice system professionally
as employees so most of them presumably
are agents of racism would that be
correct in your view sure because
they're inside there they're operating
the system particularly to look at st.
Louis County and I think this is why
it's such a great example if you are a
black police officer in one of these
small municipalities that probably
shouldn't exist and only exists that
doesn't this sort of historical racism
your job is to generate fines and Di's
from black people who live in your city
in order for your government to continue
exist and or if you do continue have a
job I mean the you know the classic sort
of conservative critique of a government
jobs program is paying one person to dig
a ditch and the other person to fill it
up well here in st. Louis County you
have entire Beach counties where the
police department's
sole purpose is to generate fines and
fees so that the police department can
continue to exist that is a huge problem
and its more prominent actually in black
areas of the county in blacker cities
those cities tend to get less in less
revenue from income tax so they're more
on fines and fees so yeah I think if you
are a black person operating one of
those systems you are hurting black
residents as a result of sort of
historical legacy whatever you want to
call it systemic racism I'm not saying
those people are racist I'm saying that
is the very definition of systemic
racism it's a system that produces
raises outcomes because it was sort of
built to regardless of the motivations
that people who operate inside of it
well you would also say just to clarify
that that gets even outside that those
government a disproportionate number of
people in law enforcement are black so
they for the most part of our also
agents of racism in your view if I think
that they are participating a system
that that was designed to produce races
outcomes that is producing races
outcomes I'm not going to say their ages
of racism because that describes then
the mindset that you know I don't I
can't I can't read their mind and I'm
not sure most of them aren't racism
racist against their own guy
but they are participating in the system
that disproportionately affects the
black people in their communities and
it's a system that was designed we've
had many questions about this as a
Raphael could you clarify your position
about the distinction between results
and intent could you go over that again
yeah no I think again this is this is
the point you right Bradley can say that
the definition of systemic racism is
that you know the system and produces
the it outcomes without regard to intent
but that doesn't necessarily make it so
racism in ISM right refers to a state of
mind refers to a set of beliefs racism
requires at least some showing of intent
and the fact that met there are many
black and brown police officers
prosecutors judges lawmakers in various
parts of the country you know who have
contributed in one way or another to
some of the outcomes that Bradley cites
as evidence of racism I think undermines
his point to the extent that you buy my
argument which is that a showing of
intent is necessary right I mean in 1991
William F Buckley debated Charlie Rangel
among other people on the proposition of
whether we should end the drug war and
Charlie Rangel was off was arguing in
favor of perpetuating the drug
at one point suggesting life in prison
for certain crack dealers right and this
is this is a guy who helped push the
anti-drug Abuse Act of 1986 this was a
guy who was supportive of the
Rockefeller drug laws and so you know
the idea that someone like Charles
Rangel congressman to Harlem for god
knows how many years was you know
helping to operate a racist system is I
think really strange patchouli yeah okay
with respect to if you love these
specific examples that Bradley has used
could you address a couple of them that
you perhaps did not specifically speak
to Raphael in particular for example he
mentioned that that jurors on panels
during blacks are not chosen to be on
juries where whites are and that that's
that obviously harms black people or on
trial before those jewelry's he
mentioned a degree of blackness bias and
backed people who are very black tend to
be mistreated more than but then the
lighter skinned blacks those two
examples do they mean anything to you
what's your response yeah I mean I can't
I can't say that I am thoroughly
familiar with all the literature on jury
selection but I can say that there are
mechanisms that are exercised pretty
pretty often to vindicate those rights
it's called a Batson challenge and and
there are many of those cases that that
make their way through I would point out
here in New York City in Manhattan where
you have more white jurors on criminal
trials there is a a much higher rate of
conviction in jury trials and in the
Bronx which has one of the lowest rates
of jury trial conviction and and much
higher proportions of black and brown
jurors and so you know I think that's
that's pretty good evidence that at the
very least this trend is not nationwide
it is not something to character
this system as a whole and this is I
think another problem that these
arguments suffer from which is that you
take these stories we take this one
study and we pretend that it represents
the entire body of literature or we
pretend that it that it characterizes
the system by and large and that that
just isn't the way reality works and you
want to say the same thing about the
degree of blackness studies that I mean
you know this is I have no doubt that in
some aspects of life you know skin tone
is you know is a factor I I I just again
I have not seen those studies I can't
speak to their methodological integrity
I am a little suspicious of the
representation of them here today but
yeah I just I can't speak to something I
haven't seen actually i I've got a few
questions about the crime rate issues I
want to go back to it just remote radley
it did seem to go possibly as high as 20
to 25 percent in attributing the decline
in crime to more aggressive policing and
incarceration up that 20 to 25 percent
hopefully rather stepping you did quote
that ugly a Rafael could you could you
pick your number do you think yes right
oh that's - well it's 25 percent to be
clear just for incarceration that does
not include the role of policing right
so so and so that that sentencing
project study from 2005 which cites
several pieces of literature including
some done by Steven Levitt came up with
that 25 percent number and that is
attributable just to the world of
incarceration right policing on top of
that 25 percent has produced all kinds
of benefits again that have been iord
primarily to the benefit of black
communities and again the main point
here is that when proponents of the
criminal justice system when defenders
of the criminal justice system talk
about it they talk with reverence about
these crime declines this is something
that we are proud of right and that
reality does not mesh with the claim
that the system is racist right it just
doesn't make any sense that the racist
system operated pursue in a way that
achieves its stated goals as per the
people running that system benefits
black and brown Americans to that high a
degree that does not make any sense
maybe I took your name in vain
Radley do you want to make a comment
about the question I just put to Rafael
of any any episodes anybody bottle of
you what do you want to say no I did I
mean I I think it's it's a mistake to
sort of say I mean the system if the
system benefitted black people by by
reducing the homicide rate in black
communities
it also sewed a lot of misery and
despair upon creating you know entire
generations that like we knew people who
were incarcerated or had a parent or
family member in car serated who have a
criminal record or have an arrest record
you know over policing it is in mass
incarceration have had a monumental
effect on black the news in US and say
that you know maybe 20 25 percent which
it's a very difficult number to measure
of the crime drop they've been tributed
it's that i think we have to factor in
the harm that was done by this policy as
well yeah i mean i i would i would just
respond quickly by saying that you know
it's no more difficult to put a
dependent that tail on the on the donkey
so to speak as it is you know to just
sort of isolate the role of racism in
things like jury selection right there
econometrics is an art you know so the
idea that that we can just sort of say
well yeah that's that's that's too hard
to do but these you should you should
believe is a little a little uneven but
i also want to respond to this claim
that incarceration is harming families
because it is a valid argument if you
buy it the problem is is that the
evidence doesn't jive with this write a
new working paper out of out of the
University of Ohio out of Ohio I should
say I'm going to quote it now because I
wasn't planning on talking but it's a
contrary to conventional wisdom parental
incarceration has beneficial effects on
children reducing their likelihood of
incarceration by 4.9 percentage points
and improving their adult socioeconomic
status sibling incarceration leads
systems similar results in criminal
activity now the paper which is entitled
the effects of parental and sibling
incarceration evidence from Ohio was
co-authored by researchers at the
University of Chicago UC Berkeley and
USC and what they did was they studied a
sample of children with parents quote on
the margins of incarceration in other
words parents whose incarceration status
would depend very heavily on the
leniency or severity of the judges
handling their cases and they measure
not only life outcome differences
between the children with incarcerated
parents or siblings and those without
but also the portion of those different
those those differences attributable to
the parents incarceration and this is
not an anomalous study right this is
part of a growing body of research that
resembles other findings right so in a
study of incarcerated parents living
with their children in North Carolina
the University of Colorado professor
Steven Billings found a quote removing
negative potential role models through
incarceration benefits children end
quote particularly in terms of their
behavior at school a paper out of Norway
estimating quote a thirty two percentage
point reduction over a four year period
in the probability of the younger
brother being charged with the crime if
his older brother is incarcerated and
Carolina Ortega in economists out west
in the 2008 read study of children in
Colombia found the conditional on
conviction parental incarceration
actually increases years of education so
this idea that incarceration can just
automatically axiomatically be
considered a net negative for children
or families is is not supported by the
data I'm kind of dumbfounded by this
argument the idea I mean rooms like the
like Manhattan have been saying for
years that you know the breakdown the
black family is responsible for all
these social ills in the black community
and the absence of fathers is critical
but now all the sudden incarceration
that's good for children children having
parents in prison it's good for them
it's gonna be to better outcomes I mean
that I don't know these studies decided
this fly in the face of dozens and
dozens of studies showing Lea harms
incarceration not just on families
incarcerated than the entire communities
and neighborhoods and that there's a
there's actually it's a
model or incarceration can effectively
music cease I mean the act I guess I'll
have to check out these studies but
there's an overwhelmingly more willing
amount of empirical evidence that
contradicts them so again there's an
overwhelming body of evidence that shows
that incarceration does harm children
the question is whether it harms an
unmet right as compared to what now
whether a parent's presence in the
child's life is beneficial will depend
very heavily on whether that parent
engages in high levels of antisocial
behavior right this is a term that
researchers have been looking into for
about 40 years in the psychological and
sociological literature right and when
when people you know fail to conform to
social norms when they act deceitfully
impulsively with reckless disregard for
others right the literature on the
intergenerational transmission of
antisocial behavior is actually pretty
robust and what it suggests is that the
presence of parents who engage in such
behavior may actually be even worse for
a child than the absence of a pro-social
parent right so I'm going to quote
another study published in the Journal
of abnormal child psychology which found
who fathers antisocial behaviors
predicted growth in children's
externalizing and internalizing behavior
problems with laying stronger among
resident father families right another
paper in the journal child development
found quote the quality of love a
father's involvement matters more than
his mere presence and that children who
live with fathers who quote engage in
very high levels of antisocial behavior
will go on to behave significantly worse
than their peers whose fathers also
engage in high levels of antisocial
behavior but do not reside with their
children so the idea that this does not
fit within the broader literature again
it's just not true you I wrote an entire
essay about in City Journal called
fathers families incarceration you can
check it out there that also assumes
that antisocial behavior people who are
imprisoned I've been gay are engaging in
antisocial behavior it just counts the
fact that you know arresting people for
drug possession giving people criminal
records leads to antisocial behavior
because you take away opportunity from
them you take away you know chances for
them to just sort of live normal life be
present in your communities present
their families it also assumes that
there's a strong correlation
people were prison imprisoned the reason
because of their antisocial behavior and
I think there's a lot of examples to the
contrary to that as well
we don't you know the level of
incarceration is not legislated the
level of which people are in tight
social or engage in antisocial behavior
well what I would say in response to
that is that again here there's there's
actually a pretty decent amount of
literature looking at the rate of
antisocial behavior in prison population
so in 2002 The Lancet published a study
that showed that nearly half of just
under nineteen thousand male prisoners
surveyed across 12 countries had
antisocial personality disorder a 2016
article and translational psychiatry
noted that while only between 1 and 3
percent of the general public have
antisocial personality disorder the
disorder has a prevalence of quote 40 to
70 percent in prison populations so you
know again there there's there's just a
lot of data here that says you're wrong
well there's no rafi I guess I radley
might respond I forgive me for me wasn't
you in that rally that once you went to
prison it could make anybody antisocial
is it yeah there's certainly some
evidence to suggest that the prison can
have a criminal genic effect on people
but that doesn't explain what landed
them there in the first place and we
know that prison is nowhere near a first
sanction for most people right only
about 40% of all state felony
convictions result in a post conviction
prison sentence so the idea that it's
new prison sort of making all these
people you know sort of fall into these
antisocial patterns as opposed to you
know these people having antisocial
patterns that lead them to prison again
I think strange connealy I would also
suggest that you know getting stopped
brisk 20 or 30 times the course of a few
years we've been leaving your home of
getting pulled over 40 times or the
course of your life you know despite not
doing anything wrong Michael so you know
eventually lead to some antisocial
behavior questioning the way society
treats them yeah I was just gonna say
look at you know that that might
contribute some sure I mean and the
false-positive problem is a real one
right I mean if these crime trends are
driving some police perceptions and
their driving police resource
into these neighborhoods there is going
to be a high rate of false positives
within the demographic groups and those
papers again that does not necessarily
mean we can cat it we can characterize
the entire system by that and also again
I would just say that usually antisocial
personality disorder is developed it of
extremely young age before anyone's had
any of those interactions with law
enforcement I've got a question I've
gotten a couple of questions that maybe
don't specifically address your
disagreements but people are interested
in in this particular question that
would put to you both
what would since or anyone scream
roughly also but what would you if you
had your druthers want to change about
the criminal justice system I'll put
that to your first Raphael and then
Radley Raphael what would you change
oh man well I I would certainly change
our systems propensity to repeatedly
release repeat offenders who have proven
themselves dangerous to society and have
been gone on to victimize their
neighbors again mostly black and brown
Americans I'm thinking here of a story
of a woman named Brittany Hill in
Chicago in 2018 who was standing outside
at the age of 24 holding her
one-year-old daughter and she was
talking to her baby's father when a car
drove up and the baby waved to the car
actually just before the passenger
window opened up and a man stuck a gun
out and opened fire wounding Brittany
Hill fatally as she shielded her
daughter from gunfire at the age of 1
and she collapsed in the street and she
died with her daughter in their arms and
the the shooting was captured on a
Chicago Police Department camera and so
they were very quickly able to apprehend
the suspects one of whom was guy named
Michael Washington who had nine prior
felony convictions nine convictions
including for second-degree murder was
on parole and four at the time and out
on bail on pending charges you know I
could go on for a really long time about
things I would change about the criminal
justice system but the tragic stories of
absolute carnage and destruction of
families through violence that is a
result of our systems leniency on too
many violent high rate offenders
to me has to be at the top of it was all
right well since Rafael limited himself
to one Radley we're gonna limit you no
more than two what are two things didn't
you change one of the half things you
change about the criminal justice system
well you could go to two right there
there are a lot to choose from but at
first I would dramatically reduce the
policing footprint in this country I
don't think we need police officers for
example conducting or doing traffic
enforcement other ways to do that
without armed for the agents of the
state confronting you for you're running
a stop sign or red light I think using
police and traffic enforcement increases
the number of contacts between police
and and particularly again in minority
communities increases number of search
increases the number of opportunities
for situations to escalate I think a lot
of highway traffic enforcement can be
done in other ways including just
engineering and Road design good
examples are in Europe we could look to
but then the other thing I would change
is I would I would try to and this is
kind of more theoretical I guess but I
mean I think we need to think about why
we have a criminal justice system and
what it's designed to do and I think you
know switching from a retributive model
to more of a rehabilitation model would
go a long way again we can look to
Europe at examples the prisons are
designed to rehabilitate people not for
just for to subscribe sleep our thirst
for retribution out on people to commit
crimes certainly there are some people
who need to be kept from society for the
safety and benefit of society but you
know as you touched on earlier Gina
there's there's lots of data showing
that when people go to prison it makes
them more violent when they come out
than when they went in that prison
actually contributes to recidivism we
could change that model and we could
look to other countries that have
successfully done that and work to sort
of rehabilitate people work with people
to commit crimes to improve their odds
of succeeding when they get out as
opposed to right now which you know we
make it very difficult for people to
reenter society after they leave prison
and that's bad for them but it's also
bad for us and I think I think change
so the way we look at what's in store
isn't back again one final question I
put to you Raphael what's come through
Radley has said that many of these many
of the studies that he cited do control
for higher rates of crime or control for
similar kinds of crimes committed by
blacks versus whites and then you said
that those controls have not really been
made and you talked about increase the
concentration of police forces in high
crime areas that are often black could
you that seemed to be your explanation
for the lack of control in these
statistical studies the audience is
asking for you to clarify your position
in that regard well I think I would I
would disagree with the characterization
of the studies that that that Bradley
has has sort of collated as largely
representing pieces of literature that
actually control for all the relevant
factors like I said I mean I have not
audited the entire article but as
Bradley was just giving his rebuttal I
was able to go through the first 19
listed in his article and and none of
those had anything approximating the
appropriate controls right if for
example a study finds a sentencing
disparity along racial lines that also
controls for criminal history that
doesn't mean that criminal history is
the only relevant control right there
are other factors like severity of the
crime for example right not all
robberies or equal you can you can do an
armed robbery and no one gets hurt you
can do an armed robbery and potentially
shoot someone right then you it also
doesn't necessarily reflect the actual
charges that been instituted the
prosecution in the first place again
most of these cases are decided be a
plea bargain where charges are dropped
or modified and so what people actually
go to prison for does not necessarily
represent you know what they did and so
to look at two robbery convictions as if
the behavior was identical I think is
the wrong way to look at it rather on
the QA but you have
we're gonna go to the final part want to
take a few extra seconds to respond to
what Rafael said you can do so seven
half minutes for your final summation in
Radley that'd be adequate
take it away Radley go ahead sure so I
want to respond to what he just said
because I find it hard to believe that
in the five minutes that I had for
rebuttal he went through the first 19
studies that I listed and was able to
sort of pinpoint where they failed to
correctly adjust for you know crime
rates or you know geography or whatever
else you think they need to adjust for
that sort of strains credulity in my
mind one of those studies in fact was
one a study of 95 million traffic stops
which found basically the black people
were more likely to be searched that
they were less the disparity actually
lessened as it got darker which suggests
that these were unable to identify less
able to identify the race of the driver
race became less of a factor and who
they pulled over and found out the
police were more likely to search black
motorists fights affected such as of
white people were more likely to turn up
contraband and that latter point as I
pointed out in my introduction as found
has been repeated over and over and over
and over again these studies rabi I'll
never sort of dressed why that would be
and that seemed to be a study that's
pretty indicative of a hard disorder I
think there but because you know if it's
true that you know black people are
committing or we're more likely to be
carrying drugs or weapons than maybe you
could explain why there are more likely
to be searched that's it's actually the
opposite of that you know I would just
say in summary what you get when you
when you debate someone like raffia or
other people in Manhattan is they they
they tend to cherry-pick a study or two
or three or four that confirm what they
have to say and they write about it as
if this is the only study that was done
on this planet they don't acknowledge
the fact usually that there are dozens
of studies that contradict what that
study it just just concluded a good
example is I did a Google Trends search
last week on by the name Roland fryer is
the the Harvard professor who did a
study on pieces of force and found that
well
Thompson's were more likely to use
sports against black people they were
less likely to use lethal force this
becames are they a very popular study
for people on the right to site and
trying to contradict the claim that
black people were more likely to be
killed like police learn a lot of
problems of that study one have relied
on police reports on their own
activities which is always a problem and
an inherent problem I think it's none of
this data but also the police the study
on police force was limited to one city
but regardless of that that was one
study there have been multiple other
studies since that one came out they've
come to the opposite conclusion or in
various ways and they've tried to adjust
for other factors and I did a Google
Trends search just the other day on this
and found that on his name and then on
the name of the lead researchers and
five other studies that have come out
since his and we're talking about right
be the protests and you know it's very
we're having sort of a moment for these
issues and citations to his study were
speaking mentions in his study and
Google searches for yeah outnumbered
searches for the other five lead authors
combined and my point here is that you
know it's easy to sort of generate
attention to the one study that finds
the the no no racial disparity and so
that's for criminal justice system when
you know literally you're you're having
dozens of studies coming to the opposite
conclusion over and over again it's the
kind of what what is news dog bites man
or man bites dog but you know I think
it's important if you're going to make
the point if you're gonna sort of buck
the tide on this that you have to
acknowledge all of the data and
literature that them via the opposite
inclusion that's rarely done in these
cases I mean I would just say that you
know when I started on this beat with
Reason magazine in 2005-2006
you know I came from a pretty
conservative background I grew up in a
very conservative county in Indiana and
I was very skeptical of claims its
criminal justice is inherently
inherently racist i I accepted the
problems and in systemic problems and I
think that's still true I think there
are problems that affect white people
and black people alike but I think the
problems disproportionately affect black
people and I think that is by design
because the way the system was sort of
know
and only over the years you know it was
working on this beat it was you know see
doing the investigations that have done
it was research at then was talking to
people needs communities talking to law
enforcement leaders I mean there are
people within the law enforcement
community black and white who will admit
that the system is a raised system and
it has and that the racially
disproportionate outcomes are not the
result of necessarily of input it's
partially the result of inputs but it's
also the product of the system itself I
think the evidence I would encourage
people to go to the Washington Post's
Page where I think you lated these
studies and sort of look through them
you can judge for yourself how well they
adjust for the things that we Raphael
thinks they need to adjust for you know
if you have a very sharp mind I guess
maybe you've been awed it 19 of them in
five minutes but I think the evidence is
overwhelming and as I said you know I I
included studies that have come to
opposite conclusions at least the extent
that I found them I'm gonna continue to
update the list but so far you know the
ratio of studies that have found
disparities and those haven't are about
25 to 1 you know I would just close by
saying we again that the idea that we
have a criminal justice and that is
systemically racist is not an indictment
of your but of everybody who works
within that system and I think Rob elo
has been sort of willfully I don't know
miss stating what systemic racism
actually means are lawfully failing to
acknowledge what the definition of it
actually is it is the acknowledgement
that this is a system that was designed
to produce very specific outcomes that
it was designed during an era where I
think even Raphael would admit that we
had systemic races in this country we
had we had legal legally enforced
segregation in this country and the idea
that sort of just pulling away the the
laws that that mandated segregation and
keeping the institutions that were alive
and perpetuating and contributing to
that without significantly altering or
changing them you know we should not be
surprised that we have a system that
produces the outcomes that it has all
right thank you Radley and now Raphael
for your estimation take it away Raphael
yeah well I'll start by just kind of
responding to a few things first off I
what I went through are the first 19
characterizations of the study's
findings by Radley not the studies
themselves and all those
characterizations were focused again on
on disparities not just the presence of
disparities in other words not actually
saying that these studies controlled for
the relevant factors that isolated the
role the racial animus played in
producing those disparities I did also
respond to the evidence that he
presented about likelihood of being
searched right I offered evidence out of
New York showing that the City Council
found that black Americans were more
likely to consent unwittingly apparently
to requests for a search and again
Roland Friars is not the only study that
has failed to find where bases of racism
in fatal police shootings there was
another study and the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences as well as
several other shoot don't shoot
experiments and there's one that I want
to talk about really quickly which which
is interesting because it found that
officers who basically the study looked
at at gang unit officers at regular
police officers and then civilians and
it compared their performance and shoot
don't shoot experiments and then it gave
them a bias training implicit bias
training and then it had them do those
experiments again and sort of compare
the results and and what it found was
that officers who routinely dealt with
both stereotype congruent minority gang
members
we're actually less likely to exhibit
differences in the racial breakdowns of
their shoot don't shoot decisions after
bias training and this supports the
hypothesis that race may actually be
taken as a diagnostic cue in the field
by police officers at least in in those
simulations because quote they're
on-the-job experience with gang members
and street crime creates a stereotype
congruent environment that allows them
to rely more heavily on heuristics and
and people should be troubled by that
but again the question is is whether
they're relying
six out of racial animus or out of a
desire to suss out crime and what that
study found was that the gang police
officers actually showed no evidence of
racial bias in their ultimate decisions
tissue they were just as equally likely
to shoot across racial groups and the
gang unit cops specifically outperformed
comparison groups in detecting guns and
we're overall the least likely to shoot
suspects you know again I think
ultimately a you know a big chunk of our
difference here is that I reject
Radley's definition of systemic racism I
think we have to show and establish that
there is this is intent here and again
for all the reasons I stated earlier I
don't think that we can find intent you
know for disparities you know cannot be
conflated with racism there we have to
actually control for the relevant
factors to isolate the world of racism
might be playing you know the the
reality is is again the criminal justice
system has more than just enforcement
outputs and every operator of the
criminal justice system at least claims
to want to bring about crime declines
and applauds when those crime declines
happen in the fact that those prime
declines and you're primarily to the
benefit of black and brown Americans I
think drastically undermines the claim
that Bradley's defending here again the
system has been incredibly responsive to
calls for reform which are often rooted
in in the idea of combatting systemic
racism and the idea of anti racism right
we have evidence just recently again out
of New York we got you know Governor
Cuomo's I need ten laws you know just
just weeks after a George Floyd was was
unjustly killed right and and we've got
just that's not the first the first or
only thing that we've done we seen a
wave of progressive prosecutors elected
across the country we've seen
prosecutors offices you know shift a
supporting parole
we've seen them declining to prosecute
more minor offenses we've we've seen
here in New York through the passage and
signing of the right to know act
received a closing of Rikers Island
we've seen the cut in jail admissions
and
and state-level incarceration we've seen
bail reform discovery reform raise the
age you know the fact of the matter is
is that a system apparently dedicated to
the oppression of black and brown
Americans would not be so responsive to
their calls from reform and I think the
fact that is is another point that just
undermines the the claim that Brad was
defending here he also again ignores I
think they also have a really good
explanation for the world of black and
brown Americans play in apparently
perpetuating racism and and the reason
that he's able to do that is because he
puts intent off to the side which I
don't think we can do this is a very
serious charge and I don't think we can
just attach some flimsy definition to
with the term that says amorphous is
systemic racism and and allow people to
get away with that because it does have
very real consequences right people will
call nine-one-one less people will be
more likely to try and handle disputes
on their own which could lead to more
neighborhood violence this is not a
benign narrative and you know to the
extent that it's being used you know to
perpetuate mordy policing and dakar
serration I would point to evidence out
of Chicago just in recent weeks right
while police were busy handling riots in
other parts of the cities that we can
have May 31st Chicago experienced its
most violent Week in Review
sort of coincidence I mean May 31st was
the single most violent day in Chicago's
history since 2000 since 1961 when it
when it started a keeping track I don't
think that's a coincidence and again the
idea that defenders of the criminal
justice system consistently as I do as
Heather McDonald does as police leaders
across the country you do argue that
it's black lives that are going to be
saved by the crime declines attributable
to the policies that they support I
think again just shows that there is
absolutely no intent to produce racially
disparate outcomes for its own sake the
reality is is that many of the
disparities that we see even not all are
attributable to differences in crime
Commission and and and are our functions
of a mission that is essentially
knowable at its core and I think you
know that something I'll have to
remember and
all clothes there okay well thank you
Raphael thank you Radley for a very
lively and informative debate exchange
Jane please open the file vote on the
resolution many of you have not seen
this livestream and will enough cast an
initial vote and so we're gonna give you
a chance those who have not seen the
livestream but we're watching the video
and the audio will be giving you a
chance to watch the video in audio once
it's released this Friday and will be
giving you a few days to decide on your
final vote the results will be announced
next week thanks to all of you for
watching we'll certainly have more
online debates like these in a few weeks
we will have a debate on the
presidential election up but I hope that
will be online but I hope to see all of
you at our physical space at the
subculture theater in the
not-too-distant future
good night and thanks